[Music]
some things happen like I read that you
know after Freaks and Geeks you were
depressed because about one season well
I work again you're talking about
working in the coffee industry what was
it as a barista for one day maybe five
hours I made two dollars not to brag
from the tip jar someone was nice enough
to say here take this I was in my early
20s at this point and I just didn't feel
like I was going to work out in this
business and I didn't I think I've lost
some passion for it too at that point
because it's sucks like the people that
you it's a business and when you meet
enough of just the business and you get
beat to by the business
you're like wait the thing that I love
doesn't exist here anymore
you really thought no one's gonna cast
your acting careers over yeah I did I
didn't I didn't really feel like it was
a place where I could thrive anymore
that I had the kind of relationships
that were valuable just because it's I
love working and I love meeting new
people and I love new experiences like
that spider-man is one that was very fun
obviously Silicon Valley now those have
become family and and those are the
experiences that I only want that's all
I'm here for and and ending up on a show
where it isn't like that or doing doing
something that feels like business like
the only purpose that most of the people
are there with is to make money it that
isn't that isn't what I'm interested in
and that's what it kind of felt like was
only possible and that was shunning me
so I've I got really lucky
knocked up happened and then my life
shifted do you think you're grown-up
enough maybe not the turn do you think
you're mature enough do you think you
have had enough life hit you in the face
that if something happens now or you
don't work for some reason and you just
stop working for a while that you would
have that level of like I'm not gonna
fall apart I'm not gonna get depressed
I'm gonna do what I can and figure it
out never I don't think it's possible
for me I I also what do you mean it's
not impossible to do what I I don't
think it's possible I don't think that's
how I'm wired well even when we would
shoot Silicon Valley and I felt
confident because HBO was so
was such a proponent of the show and was
so supportive and with us I felt always
good that we would come back season one
two three like once once season two
happened then I was like oh great we'll
run as long as we want to as long as I
can Alec are excited about this we're
rolling and even then at the end of
every season there's just it's like
going to a wedding or a bar mitzvah or a
party for months where you like go and
you see your friends and you're like
this is the best this is the best thing
that's ever happened the weekend's over
and do you feel like and it's
all over that's how you feel and yeah
you get depressed oh absolutely
like when you talk about depression do
you talk about like it's situational
depression or is it really like if this
show doesn't come back what am I going
to do no it's a yeah it's a situational
it's definitely not it's more just like
lashing out probably at the people
around me and and and wanting to like
sit at home and sulk a bit for a bit but
that that that's something that I think
fades within a couple weeks and there's
still kind of like a lingering like just
missing digital effectively yeah for
what that was